guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists dot-com / tour we'll
see you there how to keep up with good
habits when you are depressed so how do
you keep up with good habits when you're
depressed that's a difficult one right
depression
it depends what we mean by by depression
obviously right do we mean your brain
inflammation that is causing you some
sort of neuro chemical response or do we
when we say depression do we do we
simply mean you know sadness or feeling
like I'm in a funk or I stubbed my toe
and now I'm feeling depressed so we use
this term depressed very loosely when
there is this the spectrum of emotion
but let's assume that liza here means
clinically depressed yes
yeah and and and in fact what I would
say is that quite often our habits or
what helped us out of the the depression
or a routine can help us out of the
depression but I'd love to hear your
perspective that's so tricky of course
if I was sitting with liza right if she
was here and it was her and i alone and
i had the space and permission i'd say
tell me about your life liza because
there's probably something there I mean
there's usually something there yeah and
so I would be I would be remiss if I
didn't try to understand what brought
her to this particular moment in time
feeling this particular way habits or no
habits you know I mean you know it can
be if you've had a lot of loss a lot of
trauma a lot of deprivation as a child
it can be hard to take care of yourself
or get into self-care habits or to move
away from self harming habits because
that script is set and you know if it
are any therapist listening to this you
know the superficial sort of well let's
just deal with what's happening now
because the past is in the past
is I think short-sighted and I think
we're miss we're not we're under serving
people I think the way that we serve
people is by helping them go deeply into
what where it started right I mean I
meet people all the time you know who
come to the care farm to do work on
grief that happened when they were six
years old because that's when their
father shot himself and now they're 40
and it's affected his whole life without
even realizing even realizing it and and
and other people blaming you know him
for these maladaptive behaviors that
were coping mechanisms when you're six
and your dad shoots himself and the
whole family is spun out right and they
just become part of your habitual
patterns yes right and so I would I
would really have to take her deeper
into that and say let's talk about this
right because it's hard to self-motivate
when when you're being weighed down by
the unexplored past the the word that
stands out to me here is habits and I
like to delineate habits from routine
and of course she also says good habits
here which is important to recognize
because just because something is I have
it doesn't make it a good thing in fact
most of our habits tend to be bad habits
when when they aren't intentional right
when we have a risk right right when we
haven't been deliberate about about
bringing these new habits on so I think
if I were to rephrase her question maybe
the thing that I would say is how do I
keep up with a good routine because if
it is truly habitual than it is just a
habit you will continue to do it but
when trauma strikes or depression
strikes something like that it may throw
your routine off significantly and the
thing that has helped me in the past
when when dealing with with depression
or dealing with trauma is having those
habits to actually to fall back on and
when they are truly habitual you know
whether it's exercise or reading or
writing I tend to do them even you know
on the bad days so to speak and I know
that they actually the good habits help
me cope whereas the bad habits there
they're the path of least resistance but
they don't help me cope at all yeah yeah
I think the only thing I you know that I
could add to this is you know maybe she
has had some good habits that are now
she's not doing don't introduce any more
bad habits don't introduce any bad
habits just because you're not keeping
up with your good habits yeah don't
don't start to introduce bad habits